The latest in a series of attempted replacements
for fired Fox News propagandist Tucker Carlson
is Donald Trump's own former press secretary,
one of the most dishonest people in the Trump
administration, Kayleigh MCENANY.
She gets this week to try replacing propagandist
Tucker Carlson.
Her first episode last night was a pathetic
joke, the likes of which you would find at
the bottom of a barrel, a media barrel, a
proverbial media barrel.
She opened her own show by showing some of
her speech at the 2020 Republican National
Committee.
I'm not going to play it, but we're just showing
you a screenshot from that.
Her first guest was the Texas attorney general
and he was on.
Not to talk about we've got to do something
about guns.
We've had this terrible shooting in Texas
and.
Allen.
No, no, no, no, no.
The Texas attorney general appeared with Kayleigh
MCENANY, Ken Paxton, to talk about how bad
gender affirming care is for trans kids.
And then this was really just the cherry on
top, I guess we would call it.
Former Democratic Congresswoman Tulsi Gabbard
appeared to call trans people mentally ill
and essentially say that there's no such thing
as trans.
She says really crazy things here.
And this is one of the most disgusting one
of the most disgusting Tucker Carlson fill
ins that I've seen so far.
Let's listen to the last real liberal.
Remember when all these supposed leftists
were saying the only real left winger running
in 2020 is Tulsi?
Listen to this.
Well, Kelly, this should give us some hope
to see that there is still some sense of of
common sense and sanity in our society, because
this is the real question that we, the American
people, are being faced with.
We have leaders in the Democratic Party, unfortunately,
and those in our society who are are pushing
this fantasy.
They're asking us to take something that is
clearly not real and believe that it's real.
very clearly a man.
It's not real.
So illness that creates this delusion where
you have people saying, well, I'm a man and
a woman's body.
And what's weird about the mental illness
thing is that for a long time homosexuality
was very clearly a mental illness in the DSM,
etc..
And then we sort of like came to our senses
and realized just about every animal species
as a percentage of what we would call.
I don't know if the term homosexual is used
for other species, but you understand what
I'm saying.
And then we realized, Oh, actually this isn't
a mental illness.
We should stop trying to like, treat it with
medication or convert people out of it, because
that's crazy.
And so that was revised.
And so now she's just going, well, this is
clearly just a mental illness, vice versa.
And then doctors committing in the case of
children, especially this medical.
Malpractice, trying to turn this fantasy into
reality and creating incredibly negative,
short and long term consequences.
Both.
This is nuts, okay?
Tulsi is nuts physically and psychologically.
And so that's really the question that we,
the American people, have to to ask ourselves
and to answer is, are we going to live in
a society of common sense and reality, or
are we going to buy into this insanity and
this fantasy, or are we going to allow and
this is one of the reasons I left, that the
Democratic Party is right now.
We know why she left.
We have the Democratic Party of today selling
this fantasy and and catering to it and giving
credibility to this fantasy, these mental
delusions, all because they think it'll give
them more political power, a party that is
willing to do anything, especially things
that are damaging to children.
This is so crazy, the idea that you're going
to get so this.
So I don't even know.
So as far as the Caylee filling in for Tucker,
it's a joke.
It's just terrible.
But she was better than some of the people
who have tried so far.
But the content was just absolutely disgusting.
The idea that it's I don't know at this point
what the prevalence of of trans is in the
general population.
And part of it is are we actually correctly
assessing that number?
Is everybody even kind of willing to say it
over?
But it seems like it's extraordinarily small.
It's under well under 1%.
The idea that the Democratic Party has this
brave and bold, exciting strategy to gain
political power by catering to the I'm using
their terminology by, quote, catering to the,
quote, delusions of a tiny, tiny, tiny, tiny
sliver of the population.
It's just a very stupid strategy.
And obviously that's not what it is.
It's about a reaction to the right's attack
on this marginalized group of people.
That's what we're dealing with here.
So tall, she's lost her mind.
The Tucker replacement fiasco is not going
well, and we'll continue following it to see
what happens with Fox News.
They've got another at least one more lawsuit,
at least two more lawsuits.
They're dealing with maybe three.
We will follow it.
All of the clips I played here for you.
You can find them on our YouTube channel.
You can find them on our Instagram, on our.
They're really almost too available.
To be perfectly honest.